this week was another wild one in the
bitcoin market we continue to see the
price fall and there's lots of
uncertainty doubt and fear the bitcoin
critics seem to be taking a victory lap
they think they're dancing on graves and
the big question is bitcoin over or will
it come back as it has every time before
all right let's get into this week's
on-chain update which is brought to you
by ftx as we can see here bitcoin
currently trading just over 21 thousand
dollars up about 1.3 over the last 24
hours
then you can see that the market cap has
dramatically dropped down only around
400 billion dollars or so now remember
bitcoin's inflation rate still sitting
at 1.76
and over 90 percent of the 21 million
bitcoin have been issued already you can
see real exchange volumes coming in at
4.1 billion dollars the mining reward
miners being paid just under 20 million
dollars every 24 hours to continue to
secure it the most decentralized secure
computing network in the world
gbtc the discount all the way down to 34
to nav now which is a major issue in the
industry and of course bitcoin down just
under 70 from its all-time high
if we then take a look comparing bitcoin
gold and the s p 500 you can see that
bitcoin's down 35 from just one year ago
but if you zoom out to only any other
time frame from two years to 10 years
bitcoin continues to absolutely dominate
all of the other assets
then we can go look at bitcoin prices
closing history and sitting at twenty
one thousand three hundred forty eight
dollars we coincided higher for 539 days
if you had bought bitcoin and held it
for 89 percent of its life until today
you'd be in the money but about 11 of
the time you wouldn't be
last but not least we can compare
bitcoin gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt you
can see that the compound annual growth
rate of bitcoin 124
still dominating all the other assets
and then lastly the sharp ratio
five-year basis sitting just around one
and that is much much more attractive
than the other assets
next we can take a look at this data
point which was provided by sven henrich
where he said only one more rate hike
and we're at or exceeding the historic
fed capitulation trend as the
ever-increasing debt construct brings
about a recession and the fed has to
intervene by cutting rates you can see
that red line there just down only if
the fed continues to hike interest rates
things may start to break that then
leads to thinking about what the future
market expectations are and what we can
see is for december 2023 the fed funds
rate has fallen by 60 basis points over
the last nine days according to dylan
leclair
then if we start to take a look at the
bitcoin market what we can see is that
hash ribbons which ultimately will
visualize the minor collapse as the
price of bitcoin goes down miners who
can't keep a very low cost of operations
eventually give up they could shut off
their operations and they actually start
to sell the coins that they previously
mined
bottoms in the bitcoin market in these
bear markets normally coincide with
minor capitulation the weak miners are
bankrupted adding to cell pressure in a
cascade then the ribbon recovers and
that's where you ultimately will see
those green circles in this chart from
willy woo
equaling the bottom it looks like there
is deleveraging right now as he stated
but we are not quite there to the bottom
yet
then lastly we can go and we can check
out checkmate which says all three
bitcoin envy rv cohort ratios are
underwater the aggregate market
underwater on a cost basis standpoint
long-term holders are underwater and
short-term holders are under water as
well it's exactly what you would expect
to see near a market bottom
and then of course david puel pointing
out that the mv rv crosses between
long-term holders and short-term holders
well we're there getting close again and
what this means is that the short-term
holder cost basis is actually below the
long-term holder cost basis what that
usually signals is that the short-term
holders they're in trouble eventually
they give up and usually they just walk
away now of course all of these metrics
they're great data points and you should
pay attention to each one of them but
they ultimately can't be relied on
unilaterally you have to look at the
summary of all of the data you've got to
put it all together and you've got to
say to yourself
i am only playing a probability game
if i think that i'm a day trader which
95 of you or not and shouldn't try to be
do i actually want to try to time the
bottom
or do i simply want to understand if the
structural elements of bitcoin are
actually still intact and if i can look
at the fundamentals the underlying
metrics that aren't involving price
and i see that bitcoin is still healthy
it's still decentralized it's still
executing the code as it was designed
and it's still providing the same value
and utility to end users
but the price has simply decoupled from
those fundamentals
then usually in past fair markets simply
dollar cost averaging has served really
well for those people now history isn't
necessarily a guide
in terms of telling us what's going to
happen in the future but it does serve
as a great way to understand how it's
played out in the past now speaking of
dollar cost averaging a place like ftx
allows you to buy bitcoin incredibly
cheap sometimes as much as 85 percent
cheaper than their competitors and
they're also adding digital stocks which
will allow you to buy those stocks with
no transaction fees and no payment for
order flow if you're into bitcoin if you
like these updates i suggest you go
check out ftx where you can buy bitcoin
with super low fees this is financial
advice but if you do your own research
and you take a look at all the data
something tells me that a lot of you
guys will see what i'm seeing which is
that the underlying fundamentals appear
to be very healthy and it looks like
that price decoupling from fundamentals
could just simply be presenting an
opportunity to the market
hope you guys enjoy these updates and
i'll see you guys next weekend hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you're subscribed
like the video and see you next time